hey you guys it's max and Nadine from
Max Tech and the last couple of days
we're seeing a bunch of reviews hit
YouTube hip websites and most people are
saying that the no 10 and no 10 Plus
have basically the same cameras as the
s-series
the photos are the same and they're
basically good cameras but not great now
at the event we were thinking similar
things right yeah soon as we saw the
event we basically thought that haze
got identical cameras and it honestly
just looked really underwhelming but
after using them for a couple of days
we've completely changed our minds now
we've been testing camera phones and
cameras for a number of years now and
Samsung has also always had pretty good
cameras but they never reached
top-of-the-line there are always a step
behind especially the iPhone and with
the 10s that really gave the note 9
strong beating until now when the S 10
came out they took a nice leap forward
and they matched and exceeded the iPhone
in a number of images but they just were
not very consistent sometimes it looked
great
other times there were other issues now
before we show you guys side-by-side
shots and tell you what is really
impressing us in some images that just
flat-out shocked us and change our mind
completely and made us make this video
well you know what issues we had in the
past so starting off with white balance
that was usually really inconsistent we
have actually a long list here of issues
that would pop up
yeah like over sharpening sometimes we
zoom in and see a bunch of over
sharpening especially with the telephoto
lens a lot of the time we'd experience
over saturation like the colors just not
looking realistic compared to the iPhone
colors we would get underexposing
especially when there's a person in the
frame so they would just be too dark for
the image and on top of that we had
would have too much contrast so blacks
in dark parts of an image would be just
crush the detail be gone and then under
the eyes would be pretty dark as well
and what was really annoying was that
the beauty face mode will be defaulted
on it would really just smooth out every
little detail on your face now it
doesn't do that anymore it looks a lot
better you actually see the detail
little wrinkles in your face so it
actually looks more realistic and
another thing we experienced was
aggressive denoising like in low light
it would just denoise your whole face
you just can't rid of all the details it
would just be ridiculous and I remember
like on a jacket we had like a denim one
or something with a Python and it was
completely gone now the other thing was
dynamic range and we're talking about
the previous couple phones where it was
really poor things would get blown out
clouds get blown out and it just looked
fake we would actually have ghosting
around certain things that it would try
to mix together looked really weird and
then a detail also wasn't great compared
to especially the iPhone but now we're
gonna take a look at our unbiased
comparison that we did with Angelica if
you haven't seen this yourself and you
didn't yep go in look at the photos
without knowing which one is which and
voted and commented that is a lot of fun
to see the pause this video go check
that one out it's a little have a link
in the video description but let's go
ahead and jump in and take a look if you
guys want to see our two opinions so
this is a selfie comparison this was
right when I did my triple comparison
with 1 + 7 Pro and we were really
surprised okay so both the 1 + 7 Pro and
the iPhone 10s max looked a little bit
too dark and the colors are a little bit
off but the note 10 + actually nails it
with the white balance it nails the
whole the face the lighting everything
just looks so nice and neutral and
smooth now this shot is extreme dynamic
range we have the Sun hitting the
waterfall in the background super dark
under the bridge what were your thoughts
on this one so first of all see the 1 +
7 Pro it gets these bricks back here
it's just way too dark and for the
iPhone the waterfall right here is way
too cool in overall does the white
canvas good balance and so this is an
example where the Samsung doesn't do as
good as the iPhone so the iPhone usually
is under exposing a lot of these images
and it really works out here this is
extreme even a high-end DSLR would
struggle here with the raw image next
one here and this is what absolutely
blew my mind what do you think well now
obviously you guys can actually see
clouds in the background of the note 10
plus and
surprisingly with the iPhone I thought
it would do better than this I started
with the best isn't horrible so when I
shot this I thought yeah I'm not going
to use this example they're all gonna
look horrible this is too hard of a
situation in the Samsung blew our minds
this is a 10 times zoom image so the
oneplus has a three times zoom on the
telephoto so or two it definitely is
more detailed it has that edge but color
wise where the Samsung used to usually
be to cool it actually nails to the
white balance so this one right here was
supposed to be a portrait photo but
unfortunately the oneplus 7 pro failed
to blur out the background like the
iPhone and the note 10 plus did and the
iPhone overall it was darker like it
didn't expose the paper and cup sign as
well as a NOAA 10 plus so that's why
we're going with the no 10 and then the
next one is a food photo and here
actually use the new food mode setting
so it blurs out kind of you can kind of
adjust it the one thing that I really
liked is it nailed the white balance to
reality the iPhone I don't know why it
is so blue and really cool and also
really flat so somehow I don't know if
it knows what your food is but it kind
of kicked up you should it kicked up the
the contrast but we're just here kicked
up the saturation and this is what makes
me want to eat it the happy that that's
how I kind of judged the oneplus one
looks good
and then we also had a macro shot here
yeah it looks really good I mean with
the a honestly it just kind of looks
disgusting it like doesn't have any
color in there it just looks very flat
not another contrast and with the
oneplus 7 pro it's a little bit too dark
I think it's maybe too much contrast and
overall like the most well-balanced
photo is from the note 10 plus what what
impressed me is the white balance this
is one thing I pointed out before the
white balance on the Samsung's would be
really inconsistent but judging based on
this white shot and then I switch to a
telephoto camera cropped all the way in
and the white balance is identical
between the two whereas the oneplus
actually shifted from slightly too cool
to slightly too warm the iPhone was
still too cool where the Samsung state
exactly the same okay and this one is
our first
photo portrait shot I like this image a
lot
I think the oneplus might be a little
bit better with the color slightly more
accurate but it is detailed and it
doesn't have a lot of noise because of
that faster aperture whereas with
iPhones one thing because of that F 2.8
right is it or is it a 2.5 so because of
that you don't have as much light and
there's a lot of kind of noise in the
image in this photo the first thing that
sticks out to me is you're definitely
getting more detail with the note 10
plus the iPhone looks really really flat
in your lacking contrast lacking details
lacking color whereas with the note 10
plus that's actually what it looked like
it looks really really good and look for
the 1 + 7 Pro it just looks a little bit
weird like the colors are off and you're
getting like blown out detail on the
buildings so the better photo is
definitely from the note 10 plus so this
is our first selfie portrait photo and
the note it's not perfect on the edging
but it does a pretty good job the blurry
looks good and it definitely pops the
most the iPhone is underexposed it looks
kind of flat and the oneplus it looks
really bad so this is backlit so the Sun
is hitting the lens there we get a bunch
of flaring in the corner her hair is
blown out the edging is messed up over
here it doesn't look good so here we do
have some skin smoothing yeah but it's
not over the tops good it's not over the
top now we have a selfie of a team yeah
so coming on this one so the iPhone is
slightly underexposed it still looks
really good in the situation whereas the
oneplus you look like a vampire or a
zombie blue the skin is kind of I don't
blotchy or texture nice it just looks
bad yeah exactly lifeless we're here the
Samsung you see you look like you have
my wife in your skin nice and warm you
have the sunset in the background the
white balance looks good it's a good
image so the next three photos are taken
at night and this particular one right
here first of all you can tell that the
iPhone does not have night mode like the
other two cameras do and one thing with
the note 10 plus is photo it's a little
bit too bright and a little bit
oversaturated but in general you've got
more detail the colors look really nice
so I think you'd want to take this one
home with you and here's another one
this is a selfie without flash
and so the only one that I can actually
see myself in is the Samsung and it's
nice that they now have a dedicated
night function and you can actually use
it on the selfie camera which you cannot
use with the s10 plus even with the
update now for this last image this is
also a nighttime shot and in this
situation the Samsung actually didn't do
the best the oneplus did really good
mainly because the Samsung is slightly
too bright and it's also a little bit
blurry I actually took a couple shots
here one at the telephoto and that one
looked really really great I want to
point out that we're not Samsung fanboys
as you guys know we're both iPhone users
we've used iPhones for a very long time
and we've preferred those photos up
until now where overall you definitely
want to be having the note 10 plus in
your pocket for taking photos so if you
guys aren't already subscribed I would
definitely recommend that you do so
right now click that button because I'm
gonna be switching to the note 10 plus
for a week after using an iPhone for I
think four or five years already I've
been using the iPhone so it's definitely
gonna be a very new experience so
definitely subscribe for that and we
just wanted to make this video to say
that there's been some huge improvements
we haven't expect them a lot of other
people are not mentioning them but we
want you guys to know about it and maybe
you guys are gonna be as surprised as we
were so we had to tell you so if you
guys want to see some other videos we
have a couple posted right over here
somewhere I don't know where we're gonna
put over there somewhere there's not
enough room up there you guys check out
our other videos and this one Max and
with max tech and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]